from energy Department official to a
theft Suspect with a warrant it's an
update to a story the news now
investigators first broke Vanessa Murphy
here with the latest on a request from
Sam Brinton as they face a criminal case
Brian they're still an active warrant
for Sam Britton it's for Grand Larceny a
felony theft charge Britain's attorney
and the Clark County district attorney
tell me they came to an agreement on a
fifteen thousand dollar bill that
decision will be up to a judge tomorrow
morning though the D.A telling me his
office will agree to this since Britain
is not considered to be violent or a
flight risk as we first reported Britain
is accused of stealing luggage from
Harry Reid International Airport in July
it's estimated worth about thirty seven
hundred dollars and police say they have
Britain committing the crime on video
they matched a shirt to a post on
Instagram Metro Police say they
initially hit a wall in the case until
they saw news stories for a similar
crime in Minneapolis that case is
ongoing in the meantime the department
of energy confirming Britain who was a
deputy assistant secretary is no longer
an employee by the way Britain
considering themselves non-binary so
using the pronoun they and them Britain
expected to turn themselves in tomorrow
morning Britain's attorney says they're
likely Landing in Las Vegas this evening
and the work that Britain was doing at
the department of energy is directly
related to Nevada as well Britain was in
charge of finding locations to
voluntarily store nuclear waste as an
alternative to the proposed Yucca
Mountain nuclear waste down